Hello everybody!
Sorry.
I think if I sound really sad, I think I have a reason to be sad today.
Sorry, I'm sad.
I'm sad laughing.
I'm trying not to cry because I'm very emotional right now.
I think this is why I really wanted to stream today.
Still, because I know if I don't, I'm just gonna cry.
But talking to you guys always make me really happy, cheers me up, and I know that...
I know that I'll stop crying if I get to just hang out with my dragoons.
Thank you everybody!
I'm sorry.
It was super out of my control.
I was trying to find a way to have... what's the word?
A compromise?
Because I said I was willing to delay the stream for like one and a half hours max.
But I was told...
I was told that...
It wasn't enough time.
And that for the best option, it was to be pushed back to tomorrow.
Sorry!
I know I shouldn't cry.
I know it's just silly.
It's a silly thing to cry about.
But the team did work really hard.
When tomorrow, please don't blame the project team.
Everybody that worked on it, some of them had to do crunch hours.
And they basically...
They...
I know like...
Some of them basically really haven't slept the last two hours.
Two days.
So they were trying really hard to get it done in time.
And at that point, like...
We were like...
Everybody was just like, it's just not possible.
And yeah, I would have liked to be informed earlier because I was open to pushing the date back a day or two.
But...
Everyone thought that it was possible.
So I wasn't informed until the last 10 to 15 minutes before the stream was about to start.
That it was just...
At that point, it wouldn't be ready in time.
The reason why I didn't want to push...
I didn't really want to push it back.
Too far.
Is that...
Because like...
There was another option.
It was to basically delay the stream 3 to 4 hours.
And...
Or like 2 to 4 hours.
And at that point, I was like...
It's just better to push it to tomorrow.
I was just like...
If the delay is going to be like 2 to 4 hours.
At that point, like...
We might as well just...
Stream on Sunday.
Like have the reveal on Sunday.
And...
Because like...
I know there's an overlap.
I'm not going to play dumb about it.
I...
I know there was going to be an overlap.
And I just...
I know people...
I don't want to force people to...
Make a decision.
And stuff.
And...
Um...
Because...
You know...
Both...
Both events are incredibly...
Hype and everything.
And...
Um...
I felt that...
Like...
At that point...
If it's going to be delayed...
To...
2 to 4 hours.
It was just...
At that point, I might as well just push it to tomorrow.
So I had to make...
The incredibly...
Uh...
Tough decision...
To just...
Uh...
Just have it...
For tomorrow.
And stuff.
Because I didn't want to rush.
It wasn't just this project team.
A lot of...
Um...
There's like...
Other people outside of the project team.
That also worked...
Incredibly hard...
Uh...
To have it done...
By...
This deadline.
Um...
And it wouldn't be fair...
To their efforts...
If...
Uh...
I had to rush that...
To rush my...
Uh...
New...
Skinsuit reveal...
Um...
Just because...
I didn't...
I was...
I...
Didn't want to overlap...
Or anything...
Uh...
Because I know...
Like...
There's also like...
I know...
There's...
Like...
Debut fatigue...
And stuff like that...
I...
I hope you guys...
Won't be...
You know...
Too tired...
Of debut stuff...
Re-debut...
Debut stuff...
By tomorrow...
Um...
And...
Uh...
I really do hope...
Like...
Uh...
You guys...
I know...
It won't be as hyped...
If I...
If I did the reveal today...
Versus tomorrow...
I know...
Like...
Tomorrow...
A lot of you guys did open up your schedule...
And...
I'm really...
Really really do apologize...
Um...
Cause...
You know...
It...
You guys...
It's not...
I guess I would...
Wanted to stream today as well...
Cause I still wanted to...
You know...
Cause...
You guys...
Uh...
Gave up...
Your own schedule...
To like...
You know...
Watch...
Silly me...
Watch silly me...
And...
Um...
Yeah...
I still wanted to hang out with you guys...
I still wanted to stream...
Cause you guys gave up your schedule to be there for me...
So...
I still hope you guys...
Uh...
Will still...
For those who won't be able to be there tomorrow...
I still hope you will enjoy the vibe...
Uh...
Because everybody worked so hard...
For it...
Sorry...
I know a little trick...
For those who...
Wanna stop crying...
If you don't have...
Uh...
If you don't have a stream...
To hang out with...
I'm gonna...
But...
A little trick...
Is that...
I learned this from...
Uh...
Volleyball...
I learned this from varsity volleyball...
But basically...
Cause I was crying...
Uh...
Cause I got...
I was like...
I got scolded by my coach...
For...
Uh...
Being late...
For...
Uh...
A game...
And...
Um...
I was crying...
Cause I was like...
I'm sorry...
I was late...
And then...
My coach was like...
Uh...
Drink water...
So you'll stop crying...
And it works...
She was just like...
If you're...
If you wanna cry...
And you can't stop crying...
If you...
You're crying...
And you...
And you suddenly...
And you drink water...
You'll stop crying...
And it works!
It does work!
I don't know how it does that...
But like...
I stopped crying!
Cause I just suddenly drank water...
And I started to cry...
So...
Right...
Like...
It was just for real...
And true...
Um...
But yes...
Hm...
I had to...
I get really emotional...
I think it's also...
Cause...
Uh...
It...
Um...
It's also...
Ah...
Like...
I'm really emotional...
Because I've been really stressed out...
And I know my project team...
I bet they've been...
They...
I know they've been incredibly stressed out as well...
Due to like...
Well, that worked incredibly hard for this particular project.
And I know they must have been super anxious.
They didn't want to tell me that there was going to be a delay, which I would understand.
Which I, of course, 100% understand.
Because I won't be surprised if they thought that...
They wanted to push as much as they can to get it done by today.
Which I don't blame them.
Of course, it is still sad that...
We've been hyping it for a week and everything.
And then just to hit that...
Snack.
But like I said, this team...
Was the most I've ever employed to work on something like this.
So, I know I've never had a delay that delayed this much before.
When it came to like...
Special events or special projects that I work on.
Like I try to make due with at least like one to two hours.
And if like the project team is watching this right now.
I'm sorry if I said some harsh words on the survey.
On the Discord survey.
I don't know if I was like really blunt here.
I don't know.
When I get really emotional, I can get like super blunt.
And I just... I don't fluff my words.
And I really apologize.
Because I do get like really emotional to the point where I don't fluff my words.
When I type.
You know like when you don't have...
When like...
When you're typing your words.
Like when you're typing in...
Like chat and stuff.
And...
Like in chat and stuff.
And you don't know what the emotion behind it is.
But...
When you're typing words and stuff.
Because you're not saying it.
You're not saying it and stuff.
And...
And yeah like texting.
When you're texting it.
And so like I wasn't like fluffing my words and stuff.
I was like to the point.
Like very blunt.
And I was like please in the future.
Please let me know.
Like ahead of time.
Like...
I would have... I understand.
Like I would have understood.
If... so it's like a learning lesson for all of us.
So I was like.
I would have understand.
If you guys needed more time.
If there needed to be a delay.
Like maybe...
But you just needed to tell me earlier.
You just needed to tell me like maybe even like three hours earlier.
Or a day or two earlier.
Like I would have understand.
I would have pushed it back.
Cause it's not fun to like...
Announce.
That it's been pushed back.
Like ten minutes before the stream started.
It's not.
It's not fun at all.
And so like.
It's really understandable.
And like.
There was just.
You know everybody was like really stressed out.
And cause they really really.
It's...
I hope you guys would.
Would.
Love tomorrow.
What we're bringing tomorrow.
Cause I know.
I know the hype won't be as hyped as today.
Because everybody was expecting it to be today.
Oh my god.
I need to.
Fuck okay.
I need to tell my new mama to not post.
Give me a sec.
I need to send a message.
That would.
Cause I gave a time.
I gave a time.
And I was like.
You can post it.
At this time.
I forgot.
Oh my god.
I'm sorry.
We are.
Pushing the stream.
Oh my god.
That was so fucking anti-climatic.
At least you know.
This is why it's good that I streamed.
Because I would have forgotten.
To message.
My mama.
To not post it.
Oh my god.
Cause I was like.
Yeah you can post it.
At this time.
Cause I think at that time.
Um.
It was like.
At this time.
That I should be done.
I should have my new skin suit.
Revealed.
And then they're like.
Okay.
And now I'm just like.
Oh shit okay.
We're pushing the stream.
Uh.
It was a huge delay.
That we couldn't.
Control.
Just wanted to let you know.
So you don't.
Accidentally.
Tweet it out.
Oh my god.
Oh please don't schedule.
Tweet.
That would've been so awkward.
Oh my god.
But yes we have to.
Me and my staff team.
Have to like.
Oh no.
Celia knows.
Celia knows that.
Cause they're in the server.
So they know that it's been.
Delayed.
The mama did not know.
So I needed to.
I needed to be like.
Oh okay please.
But yes like.
Um.
Oh.
I'm so scared.
I really hope it's not scheduled.
I hope it's not scheduled.
Alright we'll find out in an hour.
We'll stay until like an hour.
At least an hour to see like.
If it.
And then I'll just be like.
Surprise.
I.
Be like.
Surprise.
This was the reveal.
This entire time.
Okay.
Um.
What was I.
What was I gonna say.
Before that.
Um.
What was I gonna say before.
I was like oh fuck I need a message.
Uh.
I need to message my mama.
To not say anything.
To not accidentally post it.
Uh.
Um.
Where I messaged.
I messaged them on.
Uh.
On discord.
Um.
To not.
I don't know if they saw it yet.
So I'm just gonna wait.
Um.
Where.
Okay.
What was I saying before then.
Um.
Alright let's all be filled with anxiety for an hour.
That's great.
I basically just gave my chat.
Like now I gave my chat FOMO.
Because they're like oh no.
Now I have to stay.
Just to see if it actually gets revealed.
Now you can't leave.
Because now you have FOMO.
Um.
Anyway.
Anyway what was I saying before guys.
Uh.
No we're not gonna do a countdown.
That makes it worse.
That makes everything much worse.
Um.
I really appreciate like Mint messaged me about it.
And was like is everything okay.
And I was like no.
I literally replied back.
I was like no.
I'm crying.
Um.
I really appreciate like Mint messaged me.
And cheering me up.
Um.
And uh.
If anybody in the project team is watching.
Like I really apologize.
Uh.
For how blunt my words were.
Like I wasn't being like.
Guys for those who are wondering.
I wasn't being like.
I was just like.
You know we're all frustrated.
And I was just like.
We're all frustrated and stuff.
And we're all like stressed out.
Um.
And I was just like.
Basically I just like kept it straight.
I was just like.
Please just next time.
I know like I'm not corporate.
I'm just an indie.
But like please.
Next time I do appreciate if uh.
Uh.
If like I was told.
Like if I knew like ahead of time.
And I know I know.
Everybody is so stressed out about it.
And um.
And I really apologize how direct my words were.
For that.
Uh.
And I do get really emotional.
Um.
I actually stepped back after that.
Uh.
I invited.
Cause when that project server.
Um.
It was just.
I was basically overseeing everything.
And um.
Because of that.
Um.
From my experience.
I know when to step back.
Uh.
Like I need.
Like when I know.
Like you know from all my previous experiences.
Now I know when I have to just step back.
Cause I don't want to say something I regret in the future.
Um.
So like I said.
I told them straight.
I was just like.
I'm gonna go to the server.
Um.
And they're gonna handle all of this now.
They're gonna be my messenger.
Because I was like.
I don't know what I'm gonna.
I don't know what I was gonna say.
Cause I was so emotional.
I didn't want them to feel bad.
I didn't.
Cause I didn't want to like make them feel bad.
Or like accidentally guilt trip people.
So I was just like.
I need to be professional.
And I'm going to.
Put my staff member in the server.
And um.
And like.
My staff member is gonna handle it.
Like just being the messenger now.
Um.
And um.
And I'm gonna leave the server.
I'll join back when I.
Like I'll join back after the reveal.
Like when I've calmed down.
When I feel a lot.
Like after the reveal.
So yeah.
I like invited.
I told my staff member what was happening.
And then I was like.
Can you join the server?
And just like delegate everything for me.
And just like relay.
Send me the files.
And like relay stuff to me.
About everything if they need that from me.
And uh.
So then I just like.
I like invited.
I just invited my staff member.
And I gave them control of the server.
And I was like.
I'm out.
Cause I feel like I'm gonna say something really.
Really.
Like something I might.
Like might be like unprofessional.
Like I might get like super emotional.
And I don't want to guilt trip them.
I don't want to make them feel worse or anything.
Cause I can't help it.
When I get like super emotional.
Um.
And I'm worried that I might say something that might feel like guilt trippy or something.
Or like I didn't want to make them feel bad.
Or anything.
If I feel this way.
I am not.
I will not be surprised.
Like if I feel this way.
Like feeling incredibly emotional.
Um.
They are also feeling equally.
Or if not more so like terrible.
Uh.
Or like terrible because they couldn't meet the deadline.
So that's why like.
Uh.
That's why.
Um.
I knew that I had to take a step back.
Because if anything.
I know like that team.
Like they literally some of them were pulling all nighters.
And stuff to make sure it was done by the deadline.
And.
Um.
Like I knew that like I had to.
Take a step back.
Because like you know.
I knew like the things I did type in the server.
Would must have like hurt them a lot.
Because like you know.
I was saying.
I said like I was just.
I was just sad.
You know like I was.
I put my feelings on my sleeve.
And being like.
It's like they were like we are really sorry for the delay.
I was like it's okay I understand.
I am crying.
But I do understand.
And like stuff like that.
Like you know if I read that.
I would be like shit I feel terrible.
Because I made somebody cry.
Like obviously I couldn't stop myself.
Because like I'm like I'm upset.
And like stuff like that.
And I'm like I wish I didn't type that.
I wish I.
I wish I didn't type that for them to see it.
I wish I kept that in.
Um kept that within myself.
Because I know like obviously.
That made them feel bad when they see.
So like that type of message is for me.
Because I'm like I guilt tripped.
A little bit from that.
Because I was just like I know I can't stop myself.
I'm crying.
But I understand.
And that's why like.
After that I was just like.
I was just like I need to take a step back.
I am going to have.
My staff member.
Um.
I'm going to have my staff member.
And uh.
And so I can take a step back.
And just decompress.
And stuff.
But please like I said.
Tomorrow.
Because obviously there's going to be credits and everything.
Please like appreciate.
Like when you see why.
When you see why it was delayed.
You guys will understand.
Because it was a big project.
There was so many things going into it.
Um and.
You'll see why.
It was delayed.
Um it was.
There's just a lot going on.
It might not be a super long stream.
When it comes to like what the content is in itself.
But a lot of effort.
Was put into it.
In general.
And um.
And you guys will see why.
Um and.
Um.
I even said like.
I knew like crunch time would be a factor.
And I even was like.
I'm willing to hire as many people as I can.
To make sure there's no like.
People don't actually sacrifice their health.
Um obviously.
We didn't predict how ambitious.
The project.
Was in the end.
It was incredibly ambitious.
And um.
Even with the amount of people.
I hired.
It was still.
Not enough people.
We had to do all nighters.
And some people was like.
They got sick in the middle of it.
But then we couldn't really do much about it.
Um.
And yeah.
Even though we hired so many people.
We still had to have crunch hours.
And crunch hours.
As well as people pulling all nighters and everything.
And so they worked incredibly hard.
They worked really.
Really really hard.
Um and I saw some people mention.
They're like oh that's like really.
Like emotionally intelligent.
To take a step back.
Um it's just cause in the past.
I've learned from my mistakes in the past.
Cause in the past.
I didn't have like.
The opportunity.
To be like.
I know I'm gonna be emotional.
So I'm gonna let someone else take over this.
While I take a breather.
Um like I never had that opportunity before.
But I knew that's something I needed.
I knew that like.
If I do get emotional.
I need somebody to step in.
To like be the messenger for me.
And I need to take a step back.
So it's more so like I learned from my past experiences.
Cause in my past.
It was just me.
If I get emotional.
I get emotional.
But now.
Now I have the opportunity.
To send someone in.
To like.
Uh.
To basically you know.
Be able to be my middle man.
And be my messenger.
And when I do feel.
Like I need to take a step back.
And so yeah.
I really appreciate everybody.
For showing up today.
Cause I know a lot of people were.
Really expecting.
And were like ahhh I'm so hyped.
And I hope you guys can.
Uh still.
Have that hype.
Going into tomorrow.
Um and that.
When the.
Project does come out tomorrow.
That you guys will give.
Lots of love.
To the people working on it.
And um.
And.
Understand why.
It uh.
It got pushed back.
I mean I can obviously explain more in detail.
Tomorrow.
Cause I don't want to leak.
What the stuff is.
And like why.
I feel a lot better now.
Talking to you guys.
Now I'm not sad.
No I'm sad.
I mean I can't be like now I'm not sad anymore.
Like no cause then that would be like.
Being like a psychopath.
If I just suddenly stop being sad.
But like you know I still.
Um.
And.
Uh.
I.
I feel a lot better.
I do feel a lot better.
Like I don't feel tears anymore.
.
Uh.
I don't.
I don't feel.
Uh.
Tears anymore.
So yeah.
I really appreciate just being able to.
Talk to you guys.
Um.
And.
Yeah.
That's why I'm saying like.
Please.
Please like.
Send lots of love to the project team.
Especially when it's revealed who's being.
Like who was working on what.
And.
Um.
Because I didn't know that people were pulling all nighters.
And the crunch time.
Like people were doing crunch time.
Because um.
I wasn't um.
I was just like overseeing the.
General thing.
So I wasn't aware.
That the team were pulling all nighters.
Until today.
And uh.
Cause there's a lot of messages.
Because I have so many things going on.
Behind the scenes.
Not just from this project team.
And uh.
Um.
And I was like.
And I have other things.
And so like sometimes I don't read like all the messages.
That are going in on that server.
So I wasn't.
Aware that um.
Some of the members were pulling all nighters.
And stuff to make the deadline.
And that uh.
People were like.
People were getting like.
Crunching for it.
Because I was very open.
I was like I'm willing to hire as many people as possible.
Um.
To make sure to avoid that.
And uh.
Um.
And.
I uh.
So that's why I want to send like extra.
I want you guys to send extra love.
Uh.
To the team.
Um.
For tomorrow.
Because uh.
You know they worked so hard on this.
And.
That's why I also decided.
I made the executive decision.
To push it to tomorrow.
And.
It's just better for everybody.
Because I don't want it.
To you know.
If I push the stream.
Two to three hours.
And we didn't even get a chance to like look through.
Whatever the project was.
And like.
Just like correct it in time.
And stuff for tomorrow.
Um.
And everything.
So yeah.
That's really what I really want to say.
Again like I said I apologize.
Uh.
And you can't.
I think this is like the first time I've ever had something delayed.
This late.
I guess.
Like I had.
I uh.
Um.
I think it's like the first time I've ever.
Had to delay something.
For something like this.
Late before.
Uh.
Because usually I just.
Roll with it.
But the whole reveal centers around this.
So I.
Um.
And.
Usually I just roll with it.
And be like that's okay.
We'll just keep going.
We'll keep streaming.
And then when it's ready I'll just pluck it in.
Like plop in.
But the whole thing really relied on that.
Just like alright.
Tomorrow.
There's nothing we can do.
Tomorrow it is.
For those wondering I will not be streaming the Stranova tournament.
For day 2.
Um.
And.
Uh.
I saw someone say first time I had.
I've had delays before.
But I didn't realize with the scope of this project.
It is incredibly ambitious.
And it is in.
The scope of.
Like I said I have never paid.
This much amount of money.
To.
To do the thing that I wanted to do.
I.
I created.
There were so many things created for it.
That.
Um.
Was just like one time use.
Like.
Never to be used again.
Except for this specific thing.
And.
It was incredibly ambitious.
The scope was it was huge.
I had at least.
20 people hired for this project guys.
It was at least.
I think it was at least 20 people.
That were working.
On this project.
Um.
If not more.
I'm pretty sure.
There was a lot.
I remember scrolling through the.
The like list of people.
And there was a lot of people.
At least 20 plus.
That means there could be more.
Fuck it.
I'm going to count it.
I have the credits list.
So I can count the credits.
I'm like trying.
Okay also like I'm like really nervous.
Because I actually do have like all the stuff set up.
On OBS.
So like I'm trying to make sure I don't accidentally.
Click on anything other.
Than the chatting screen.
I'm trying to be.
Alright let's see.
1, 2, 3, 4.
Uh.
Oh wait.
1, 2, 3, 4.
Uh.
5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16.
17, 18, 19.
20, 21.
22, 23, 24, 25, 26, 27, 28, 29, 30.
Uh.
31, 32, 33, 34, 35, 36, 37.
I have 30 almost.
I have 37 people.
Employed on this.
Uh.
That was a lot more than 20.
Um.
I'm not sure.
So.
Yeah.
4, 6, 8, 10, 12, 14, 16, 18, 20, 22, 24.
Um.
So.
I.
Yeah.
This project that I'm doing.
Was.
Was very ambitious.
It was.
Um.
And.
Yeah.
It's not.
Thing is.
Like I'm worried I'm hyping it way too much.
That's.
And then when you guys see it, you're like.
Oh.
I hope when you see it you don't go like.
I said all that, but I'm hyping it way too much.
And you'll be like, wow, I can't believe you need 37 employees for that.
Not employees, sorry, contractors.
I guess you can say contractors.
You need 37 contractors.
Really?
So go in, just pretend you didn't hear how many people are hired.
And just go in with low expectations chat.
Just...
But yeah.
Anyway.
What else was I...
What else was I gonna say?
I don't remember what my topic was.
What my topic was like...
Before I...
Oh yeah!
I'm not gonna stream Shrenova.
I'm not gonna stream Shrenova tomorrow.
I'll show up for Shrenova.
You know, and I might have to leave before the tournament is over.
So I need to tell RPR to get a sub.
Just in case.
Because, you know, I told...
They apparently have...
It's apparently like later now?
The...
Um...
I don't know.
I need to look at what time the tournament is.
And...
Um...
And I need to tell RPR that there is a chance that if we do make it far, which I doubt.
I think we're gonna get eliminated in the first game.
We might get eliminated in the first or second game.
But...
If...
Uh...
If we do make it further than what I expected...
I will drop out...
At 4pm.
I will 100...
No, actually...
Because I already have everything set up.
I literally just need the project file.
I need the project file and then I'm good to go.
But like, I will leave at exactly 4.30.
Like, I don't fucking care.
I will leave at 4.30.
This is much more important.
I...
Like...
5K would only pay for one thing.
I mean, maybe not one thing.
Maybe like two to three things from the project.
Like, I do not care.
Sorry, JK.
I was exaggerating on that.
Two to three things.
Maybe.
Um...
I don't even get 5K.
Because it's split between five of us.
Bro, I don't...
Like, 1K?
I don't even know...
I don't even know like how much the prize pool really is.
Like, I don't even know the prize pool...
Uh...
On it.
So, I don't know.
Hahaha...
Um...
I don't know.
How much money did you spend on this?
I will reveal the amount after the reveal.
After the...
Uh...
After the reveal...
I will...
I will reveal it.
Hahaha...
Uh...
Oh...
Oh, hey!
They still recognize it!
Yeah...
I...
I don't know how...
I think we're gonna get eliminated after like the second game or something.
Because you guys have actual Valorant players.
And our PR...
thought that the game was Overwatch.
Uh...
Haha...
Was mostly Overwatch.
So, he recruited zero Valorant players.
Uh...
Hahaha...
No, don't tell us the cost.
Okay, what if I just keep it in the members only?
Hahaha...
And then make everybody else have FOMO.
You know what?
Yeah...
That's how it's gonna pay...
That's how I'm gonna pay it off.
I'm gonna reveal how much the...
Like the general estimate of how much I spent in a member stream.
So, you guys...
If you really wanna know how much it cost me, I will reveal it in the member stream.
Hahaha...
Because I need to...
I need to make back the amount that I spent.
Hahaha...
And yeah, I'm gonna...
Haha...
That's how...
That's how they get you.
Hahaha...
I feel a lot better.
Uh...
I honestly feel so much better just talking.
Like I said, I really do feel like whenever I do get sad, um...
I...
Um...
I love talking to you guys because it really does...
Because if I done in stream, I would have cried.
Hahaha...
So much.
And I would have cried.
I would have been like filled with like...
I guess like, you know, I would have kept everything inside.
And I would have kept everything inside and I would have been like super...
Uh...
I would...
I would just not been healthy.
So, I am glad.
Even though I can't really say like...
Obviously say a lot of like the details of everything.
I'm really happy that I was able to, you know, let out some of my frustrations to you guys.
Because...
Oh my god.
I was so sad.
Uh...
My friends were messaging me.
It was like, are you guys okay?
I was like, no, I'm crying.
I'm so sad.
Because anybody would be sad in that scenario.
You know?
I...
It was a lot of work.
Um...
I hope.
Uh...
But I really do.
DarkBlade, as a member, I don't want to know how much you spent.
DarkBlade, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Also, thank you for all the gifted chips.
Bye.
Thank you for the gifted chips.
Thank you.
Thank you for joining the tomato farm.
I really appreciate it.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, DarkBlade.
I'll say it in a member stream.
So like, I'll give like a warning, like trigger warning.
Uh...
Trigger warning.
I will reveal the amount of money I spent.
Skip to X...
Like pause.
Look away.
I'm sorry.
Oh, warning the budget.
Uh...
Thank you for all the gifted chips.
Thank you.
Okay.
Trigger warning.
Financial irresponsibility.
Making poor financial decisions.
Trigger warning.
Don't worry.
I will give you guys a warning in the members for those who are like, uh, please.
I don't want to.
I don't want to know.
Not in the port.
No.
Um...
Oh, what else do I want to talk about?
I'm really excited though for my birthday.
For those who don't know, I'm really excited for my birthday.
I don't know.
One of my five birthdays.
God, sometimes I don't even remember the fucking shit I write sometimes.
Uh...
But my real birthday, the very real birthday is July 4th.
And I'm super excited.
I'm really, really excited for July 4th.
Um...
Because there's like a lot of fun things.
Are happening in July.
I'm really excited.
Um...
It's crazy.
An entire country is celebrating my birthday.
Because I...
I showed up first.
Uh...
And anyway.
Um...
But yes!
July 4th is going to be a very, very special day.
Not just July 4th, but like the general month of July.
There's like a lot of things.
There's like a lot, a lot, a lot, a lot of things.
There's a lot of stuff coming up in July that's been in the works for a while.
Some of these things might be announced tomorrow.
Uh...
Um...
And it might be announced tomorrow.
But there's like multiple stuff going on that I'm really excited for you guys to hear about.
Um...
And...
It's...
It's a lot.
Awesome.
Being in India is so hard.
Ahaha...
Um...
Being...
Being in India is so hard, guys.
Oh my God.
Thank you.
I know a lot of people, guys.
Yes, Akka Suppa.
Thank you guys so much.
I really appreciate it.
Amelia, thank you for the Akka Suppa.
I'm sorry if I haven't thanked the other Akka Suppas yet.
I mean, like when you guys were super chatting, I was having a really deep conversation.
But yeah.
But I will thank you guys.
I'll thank you guys TOMORROW!
I trust you to deliver something amazing like you always did.
LV, okay, don't let something like this stop you.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
I really, I really, really, really appreciate it.
I think it's also because like...
Um...
I...
Really...
Um...
I really appreciate everybody for showing up.
And I really apologize if like, you know, tomorrow for some people would be Monday.
They have to go to work.
And for some, they like cleared up their schedule today.
So they might not have a clear schedule for tomorrow.
But no matter what, I really appreciate you guys for supporting me.
And for showing up if you do show up.
And just enjoying the ride.
Um... and everything.
Because being in D is so difficult.
Oh my god.
It is so much work.
Burrito, thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you.
Remember, even if you're disappointed for today's welcome for you and not the skin.
So thank you, thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you.
I really...
I really appreciate it guys.
Like I said, tomorrow when the project team reveals itself.
I want you guys to give them lots and lots of love.
Because they did work incredibly hard to make this a reality.
So I really, really, really want you guys to give them lots of love and support.
Because I know if I feel terrible, like they must be feeling like equally not just as bad.
And they deserve a lot of love too.
And...
What else...
What else did I want to talk about?
I don't...
Oh my gosh, there's...
Oh!
Next week!
Next week?
Oh my gosh.
Super hype.
But next week, Hiro invited me to try out Pal World Early Access.
She got invited to do an Early Access Pal World two days before.
Two days before the release date of the update.
So like I'll be checking out like she has a server for it and everything.
And I'll be checking it out next week.
Yeah!
We're gonna have early access to the new update of Pal World!
That's really all I have planned for next week to be fair.
And also we finished Sand Land.
And we fucking finally finished it.
We finally finished Sand Land so we can play another.
So we can finally start a new series.
Yeah!
And...
Oh my gosh.
What else?
I don't actually know.
I'm trying to think about like...
I wrote down some stuff I want to talk about.
But a lot of these things I want to talk about is usually like...
Fuck.
It's like...
It's basically...
Stuff regarding the new skin suit.
So...
So it's like...
Oh man all these things I signed up for.
Like I wrote down it's for the new skin suit.
So like I can't talk about that yet.
Um...
Let's see.
Ahhhhh...
Oh my god!
Okay.
I was so surprised.
Okay I really want to tell you guys this.
Because I was like really happy when I found out.
So um...
Apparently...
Because like one of my friends messaged me this.
One of my...
Uh...
One of my friends messaged me this.
And uh...
They were like...
Uh...
They were um...
They were like...
Oh my gosh hey.
Uh...
I was so surprised.
It made me feel so happy.
But they were telling me...
Because like...
They were telling me...
Like do you want an extra copy of like...
Elden Ring?
And like the DLC?
Do you want like a free copy of it?
And I was like...
Yeah!
I like free stuff.
I didn't buy it yet.
And I have to play Elden Ring anyway.
Um...
For like charity.
And then like...
So then...
Uh...
Apparently my friend was like telling me that...
The manager that he works with...
Like she's apparently a big fan of me.
And she was like...
She like...
Like they were...
Gave him...
Like asked him...
If like I wanted a free copy of Elden Ring.
And the DLC.
And if I want to like...
Uh...
Play the DLC during like the release.
And I was like...
I'm way too busy.
I was like...
I'm sorry.
I'm...
I cannot play on release date.
I have a million...
Million different things going on around.
And but they're like...
No it's fine.
Well like...
And they're like...
Oh we still want to send you the collector's edition.
Oh yeah!
They want to ship...
They were...
They wanted to ship me...
The DLC collector's edition.
Of...
Um...
Of the...
The Elden Ring stuff.
And so I was like...
Yeah sure!
I love free stuff!
Uh...
So yeah.
I was like super surprised.
I really want...
I remember like...
Hearing about it.
Like...
I like...
They...
He told me about it like...
Uh...
A couple of days ago.
I think like...
Like the last week or something before.
And that I was like...
I don't know.
I was so happy.
To find out that...
Um...
Like...
People working at Bandai are like fans of me.
And I was like...
Me?
I actually found out a lot of like...
Devs.
And like...
A lot of devs.
Um...
People who work at like...
Uh...
Oh my gosh!
Okay.
I can't tell you guys which sponsor it was.
But it was for like...
It was...
It's related to gaming.
And basically like...
Um...
They requested...
Like they're like...
Oh we have somebody here at the company.
That is like a big fan of you.
Like...
Can we have...
Can we send this thing to you?
And can you sign it?
Can you autograph it?
And then like send it back to us?
And then...
Um...
I was like...
Yeah!
Of course!
I was so surprised!
I was so...
It's not Hyatt.
I'll just say.
Because like...
I know...
I know like Hyatt...
Like I...
Hyatt was also like...
Um...
A...
Like a big fan too.
And I really appreciate the support they give me.
But there was a different sponsor.
It's not...
Hasn't been revealed yet.
The sponsor hasn't been revealed yet by the way.
Um...
So that's what...
If you're like...
Oh it's Hyatt.
It's not.
But I...
It was just...
It was just so sweet.
It was really, really sweet.
And they were just like...
Oh can we like send this to you?
And like...
Like because they were sending me other stuff regarding like the sponsorship.
So they're like...
Can we like send this to you?
And like...
Like because like one of our workers is like a huge fan of you.
And like could you like autograph it?
And then like...
Uh send it back to us.
I was like oh yes of course.
Of course.
Like uh I remember like um...
Uh one of my staff members was like...
Like was gonna be like...
You could say that they told me about it.
And then they're like you could say these things.
The first one was like normally you'd be like...
The first one was like...
Oh she normally doesn't autograph these things.
Like it has to be paid.
You know like meet and greet.
Some stuff or like store items.
Or the second option would be like...
Yes we'll make an exception.
And I was like no make an exception.
Like I thought it was really sweet.
Like I don't want them to like...
I don't want them to be like...
Uh like reject that.
I just thought it was incredibly sweet.
I mean they're giving me money anyway.
They're...
They were...
They're giving me...
Money anyway for the uh...
For like...
For the sponsors.
So like I don't really care.
Sorry thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Sometimes things won't go in the way we want it.
So we must blame Canada.
Yeah f**king Canada.
I love how my skin suit is...
I mean obviously it's like yeehaw cowboy themed.
And I am Canadian.
I had to...
I had to like research.
Like I had to like research like...
Like western...
The wild west in America.
The Canadian cowboys.
Yes but I'm not from the east coast.
So I didn't know anything about like actual...
I remember I was like researching.
Because like the Adithya.
The bounty hunter...
Uh...
Cowboy stuff.
Was given by uh...
Uh...
Was given by my...
My new mama.
And it was like...
You know I thought it was a very creative idea.
And when you see it you'll understand.
I thought it was pretty creative.
Um...
Because like I wanted something more...
I guess like you know...
Pew pew pew pew.
But I hate tech work.
I was like I'm fucking tired of all like...
Like Vtuber designs that are like based off of...
Um...
Like you know...
Pew pew pew pew.
But it's tech wear.
It's always tech wear.
I know.
I am tired.
I don't like tech wear.
I'm sorry.
I'm...
So I was like yee-haw.
And then my mama was like...
I don't know how to...
I...
My mama was like...
It's mostly tech wear.
But we could make it cowboy.
And I was like...
Oh my god.
That is so smart.
That is so clever.
Um...
I just think tech wear is like...
Very...
Like it's like a bit overdone now.
I won't say very overdone.
But I feel like tech wear...
Like Vtuber designs has been like pretty sort of overdone now.
And like it follows the same trope.
Like the jacket thing.
So like I feel like...
And I don't want to follow the status quo.
I didn't want to follow the status quo of like...
Uh...
You know...
You know what I'm talking about.
The tech wear jacket.
You know exactly what I'm talking about when I say tech wear jacket.
Yes.
But it's like...
It's always...
It always shows up.
I'm tired of that jacket.
I'm tired of seeing that jacket.
Yeah.
The...
The arc...
Yes!
The arc knight's jacket.
Yes.
That's so true.
The...
The arc knight jacket.
Yeah.
That's why I was like...
I don't want...
I...
I was like...
Yeehaw time.
It's cowboy time.
It's time for the cowboy!
Because I want to pew pew pew pew pew.
I want...
I want to pew pew pew pew pew.
But not be tech wear.
Um...
Anyway...
Uh...
Pew pew pew pew pew pew pew pew pew pew pew pew pew pew.
What else?
Uh...
That I want to...
What else do I want to talk about?
Um...
Oh!
Someone asked me any news on the gamersubs cup.
Um...
We...
It was a lot.
We received...
More than a thousand entries.
I...
I feel really bad for my assistant.
Because I was like...
Uh...
Our staff team was like...
Assistant...
My personal assistant.
You will...
Uh...
Go through the process of...
Um...
Like filtering out what was eligible.
Uh...
Until we were at...
Um...
What was it?
300?
Hahaha!
I'm sorry.
I haven't looked through it.
I looked at it like...
Twice.
Because even I was getting overwhelmed after it got filtered.
Uh...
Hahaha!
After the submissions...
Uh...
Got filtered.
But it took a while.
Um...
They...
Went from a thousand plus submissions...
To like...
I think 300?
I need to check it again.
Um...
But...
And it took like a couple of weeks to really...
I think it took like...
Two to three weeks.
To fully like...
Uh...
Go through all the submissions to see like which one...
Like...
Which one will be approved for me to look at.
Uh...
They're all so good.
I saw the...
The final list of submissions that I'll be looking at.
To choose top 20.
And they're all so fucking good.
It's so...
It...
I'm...
It's so difficult to pick.
Hahaha!
There's tw- I have to pick 20 submissions.
And like...
Even like the...
The filtered list.
It is incredibly difficult to pick.
I...
Looked at it like once or twice.
And I was like...
I'm gonna save this for another day.
My focus is gonna be on something else now.
Hahaha!
There's also the thing about how hard it is to be an indie.
Because it's like...
Oh my god.
Oh!
There's so many decisions I have to make now.
Hahaha!
I was like...
Will you ever...
Will you ever be corporate again?
Only if I get a really good offer.
Hahaha!
Like...
Because it's like...
It's like...
I get to keep...
Okay, not all.
I get to keep like a hundred percent.
Like...
Of my profits.
And the thing is though...
Like...
Uh...
It's like...
The thing is like...
Yeah, it's a lot hard...
It's a lot harder.
Uh...
It's a lot harder to be an indie because there's so many more decisions.
But like...
Why join a company when I...
When...
Like...
I...
A lot of stuff that...
Like...
Um...
That I'm doing already.
I'll still be doing it.
Like...
I feel like the biggest benefit for me is just the fact.
So like that's what I'm saying.
If the offer is like really, really fucking good.
Like...
I...
I don't know.
Like...
Yeah.
Um...
And...
What?
Oh my gosh.
What do I want to say?
And it's just...
It's just like...
It...
Uh...
Like the only thing that I was like...
I'm like thinking like...
Oh...
Like what it can offer me.
It's like the fact that you know...
Um...
You have a group to be with type deal.
Like setting up collabs is one of the hardest things about being into indie.
Because you know you have to...
It's easier to just be like at everybody who wants to play.
But as an indie you...
You can't add everybody.
You have to actually hit up people and reach out.
It's like I really want to play this game.
Are you like down for it?
And stuff like that.
And so there's not literally like an established uh...
Group that you like established like...
Set of people that you can just like be in at everybody.
And just be like...
Let's play this game.
Who wants to join in?
Um...
And um...
That's like...
I think like one of my um...
Biggest...
Like oh like thing that is just...
It's like one of the most difficult things as an indie.
And um...
Obviously like...
Um...
Like I said I didn't want to overlap.
Because I knew like you know I'm just me.
I'm not gonna do some fucking David versus Goliath shit there.
Like I...
I ain't...
I don't...
I'm not up for that.
I'm just me.
I'm not doing some David versus Goliath.
Um...
And uh...
Obviously like I know that I was like...
I'm fucking...
I don't...
David...
This is alternate universe.
David versus Goliath.
I'm literally endearing to record this video you know.
I mean...
I just...
This is...
Overall my time...
Guess now I passed it man.
You can learn right now.
I think like...
It's...
It's really not worth the payback.
Cause it's too much for me.
Just like you and I were at first.
We were doing better then this and...
It takes a lot.
funded...
You say that...
Anyway, yeah, I feel so much better though.
I really feel so much better.
And I do hope for those who were curious who've never...
Who've never like...
Uh, were like just showing up for the first time just to watch the Skinsuit reveal that you guys will show up for tomorrow.
If not, it's okay.
I'll just keep moving forward.
There's still so much good news, uh, going forward.
And I know like it was a missed opportunity that, uh, I wasn't able to debut the new Skinsuit today.
Um, but shit happens.
It was a learning lesson for, um, all of us.
And, uh, everybody involved.
It was a huge learning lesson.
Um, for everybody.
Um, I didn't even... I was so nervous.
I didn't even eat anything today.
I didn't even eat lunch.
Or dinner.
Um...
Because I was just...
Um, I was just incredibly nervous.
Um, I'm not even hungry.
That's the thing.
I wasn't even hungry because I was just, you know, I was just, you know, I was so...
I was just feeling anxiety about all of this.
And, uh, yes, I will eat.
I promise.
Uh, I promise I will, uh, I will, uh, eat, uh, um, after, after the stream.
Um, but I really appreciate everybody for, uh, showing up today.
Um, and I apologize to people in the...
In the chat.
You might have to go to work or go to school tomorrow.
Because it will be Monday for you guys.
And I really apologize that we weren't able to get it today.
But, um, you are going to watch the VOD.
I hope you do enjoy the experience.
And enjoy the new look.
Hey, guys!
I'm going to call it a day here.
I'm gonna call it a day here, everybody.
I know I was gonna be like, oh, I'm gonna stay up til, til like 7.
And we still have like five more minutes.
But, like, I'm scared.
I'm scared.
I'll deal with it off stream if they didn't get the message.
Anyway...
I'll see you guys...
I'll see you guys tomorrow!
I'll see you guys tomorrow.
As always everybody...
Stay hydrated.
Poster check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
Stay up from me.
Head to bed.
Because you guys...
You guys deserve it!
You guys really deserve it.
Especially if you're staying up this late.
For me.
For those who are from Inu.
And I know it's super early in Inu right now.
So thank you guys.
And I really apologize.
I'll try...
Definitely learning lesson from me.
And I'm going to work harder to keep up with the scheduling of stuff.
And like the projects and dates and stuff and everything.
But yes!
I'll see you guys next time.
Everybody.
Bye guys!
Bye!
I need to like...
Okay.
I need to make sure I don't accidentally...
I'm going to put it on...
Oh my gosh.
Is this the right screen?
We're going to find out.
We're going to find out if this is the right screen.
I'll see you guys soon guys!
Bye!
Oh my gosh.
I hope this is the right screen.
We're going to find out now.